walk out it by Oliver Luck that look at
that month driving dish
locally under day helps himself to touch
trying to get busy left unguarded on the
perimeter misses out gets his own
rebound gets the ball back and Dec can
settle for the two it's a point of
emphasis the tempo we stay playing it
already picked up a couple of EZ Pass or
Anderson breaks are out of seven
straight points for Cannes lovara 2 and
0 on the season against the Taipans
Anderson again uncontested and again
knocks down the three he's been in with
this transition in which team ill or for
rebound for rebounds this is a
triple-double of night I'm telling you
get to get on the board it changes that
and make that two points the young men
and one of that state structure but it's
also an instinct that some players have
who fear pull from a hammer
I know you hear me ham oh look at Paul
that is that's it good to meet a meter
and a half behind the three-point line
that is NBA range so good to see Angus
bother getting some early minutes seven
minutes a game averaging in NBL 20 Paul
again my goodness I might have to take
that back no no no keep them keep that
same energy gave tough journey along the
way for Angus Glover three ACLs in as
many years and it's great to see him
back out there and getting some minutes
from that flint wall driving scoring the
Charter stepping back for two
conversation about whether he should
shoot the ball more Conrad doesn't need
to be asked
ball guarded by Chris Lilley once he got
for us through the legs from there again
[Applause]
to be king to fellow people leave wife
first couple of minutes really important
here for both teams lamellae are looking
to pick up from where he left off did
everything except score lamella
hesitation step
but every trick in the book what it
saves it on we all seek beautiful
hesitation excuse me
up and under I'm going that side not the
left side the right side but here one
beautiful heads up and under nice
reverse well that's where nature why
just bit on that three it'll be with his
fifth rebound ball feeding Dave Anderson
whose foul with wonder come first it
sees the way in which he can do to
distribute the ball at six five reads
the play so well that is a world-class
move by Machado to create some space
this one
[Music]
this is the number one picking the trap
please can we have a monkey unit on
standby because our man Dory don't
commit the arousal levels I am going
through that route the margin has been
as high as 14 at various points the
melon ball the love togepi ladies and
gentlemen sis number 10 we have a
triple-double 10 seconds to work with 83
they need a 3-ball
[Applause]
three
you move out the way this man is doing
it in one of the best leagues in the
world outside the NBA
hashtag say incredible hashtag see
incredible and the thing is he's shot
actually when you see it from that angle
- he's credit it isn't it was a target
that hasn't been all that productive
this game Conrad with all the time and
space how does that happen ball driving
[Applause]
keep it going keep it going it's time
the defensive transition here we look at
bull he a little hesitation and that's
the difference and that's why you need
that tree bolt because you see fought
game part of it he pulled up a little
hesitation and he blows strike for him
but tried to throw it up had plenty of
time on the shot clock
oh my god are you gonna give him it
it's just too weak a chance to ask the
guide someday dick steps up
[Applause]